dans l'actualité internationale de ce
mercredi vous le disiez dans les titres
damien washington pour l'instant ne
change pas de position à propos de la
crise ukrainienne oui s'il dit vouloir
donner toutes ses chances à la
diplomatie joe biden continue ses mises
en garde sur une éventuelle attaque
russe en ukraine dans une allocution à
la maison blanche le président des états
unis est tout de même contraint
d'accueillir positivement les dernières
annonces de moscou le retrait de
certaines troupes massées aux frontière
ukrainienne écoutez
ministère de la défense russe annoncé
aujourd'hui que certaines unités
militaires quitter leurs positions près
de l'ukraine ça serait bien mais nous
n'avons pas encore pu vérifier cette
information
nous ne savons pas si les unités
militaires russes eux rentrent en effet
à leur base nous analyse montre encore
que les russes restent dans une position
menaçante et les faits demeurent en ce
moment la russie encore 150 mille
militaires déployés à la frontière
ukrainienne et biélorusses
une invasion resteront possibles